we're going to talk about this opening
Queens gambit declined today and I will
be showing you one of my games played at
the US Championship in 2008 against
Grand Master's Dmitri Gouda [ __ ] and I
will also talk about some lines in this
opening so I play d4 d5 so pay Knight f6
and I usually sometimes black plays
Bishop e7 here it's a very interesting
move for the idea behind this move is to
prevent a white from playing Bishop g5
immediately in for example if you go
Knight f6 I cook my opponent good which
actually took with a knight which is
considered the kind of a rare move but
still played even many grandmasters play
this Knight takes d5 move so you really
have to know what to do there to be able
to get some advantage but basically
usually black takes back with a pawn and
then you play Bishop g5 and in this
position White has the option in the
mainline to play Knight G to move and
this is what I like to play I like to
put the night only two here instead of
just Knight f3 because if you play 90 to
97 Queen c2 rook e8 this is not my game
this is just a line here you have this
idea to play F 3 and E 4 and it's a
little bit different actually usually in
this kind of structures the structure is
called calls bad black your white
usually tries to play rook b1 and play
before b5 do a minority attack but when
you put the night only two you have the
idea of playing f3 for which I prefer
here
so I think white is usually slightly
better in this kind of positions here
but this is what I was planning to play
when he played the Knight f6 Bund he
immediately avoided by playing Knight XD
5c maybe I just one second okay yeah
sorry
we take yeah sleep late night text e5 e
490 X e3 pawn takes c3 and here usually
black takes on d4 first and then plays
Bishop before check but he played 96 so
he didn't play the bishop before mostly
played 96 and here I was thinking during
the game and trying to understand why
most players play Bishop before check
and not just play 96 because looks like
you can play 96 and then Bishop before
but this will gives white an option here
so let's say what can you play here yeah
ah huh yes that's the idea I played a
three and in this position it's better
for white to keep the bishops on the
board because usually white is trying to
attack since he has the control of the
center and more pieces on the board it's
easier to attack and you will see that
this Bishop was a big part of the attack
in this game so if you play this as
black you should play Bishop before
check first but 96 and I played 83 now
he played Bishop e7 we should be three
first of course he cannot take on d4
because you just take and if he takes
with a queen you have the typical Bishop
e5 discovery check that wins the Queen
so he cannot do that so you played
castle and here I cannot castle because
if I do that then I would just lose the
pawn because it just takes the pawn
because I don't have any discovery
checks now so I have to play Bishop b2
and now if I can just cancel then I
think I have a very nice position
because I have good development control
of the center so black needs to do
something here and he did you played
Queen a5 check now I want you to spend
some time here maybe a few minutes just
to think what should that white do here
I have a few options here my king is
under check
I can go King Queen d2 exchange the
Queen's I can go 92 or perhaps I can
move my king so what do you think is the
best continuation here for white or
sonam trying to fight for advantage here
again choices Quinte 292 or move the
king somewhere yes
aha King e - well I you could do that
but I think moving the King only - it's
going to be a little bit risky because
at some point there could be some
variations where Bishop e6 comes with
the check in general it feels like king
only two will be a little bit vulnerable
here and he goes through the aid what
else you can try to do here
ninety-two you could play 92 but it
seems like now the pieces going back and
then you lose time so you look kind of
you do some temples by 92 so it's not
really ideal to play 92 in this position
because you have the night on a nice
position so if you could play 92 but I
didn't like it too much
so now we have two two more options
right so I need to choose between these
two moves play Queen d2 try to go to an
end game where you might have a slight
advantage or go King f1 so what would
you do here King a funny I think king of
fun it's more fun move to play in Queen
d2 I could play but I'm not sure if that
and again white really has anything
because a Queen d2 people probably
capture if I take with a king just b6
Bishop b7 but doesn't have any
weaknesses so I think overall maybe it's
just about equal so Rock d8 there should
be six Bishop e7 so that's why it was
kind of a not a very difficult decision
for me to play the King f1 move which I
did but of course now the game is going
to be very sharp because I lost my turn
to counsel and he's going to try to do
some ideas so from here on he's going to
be trying to do create some positional
threats and you have to find the proper
moves to stop the strats like in this
position he plays b6 what's the idea
behind this move what is it trying to do
yes absolutely he's trying to play
Bishop a6 exchanging the bishop and if
you can manage exchange this bishop and
quickly put the hook on see it and the
end it's going to be extremely difficult
to organize an attack because you know
black is very solid here it has no
weaknesses on the kingside so without my
life score bishop my attacking chances
are going to be very very low so that's
why I don't want to allow bish basics
how can we prevent that absolutely Queen
e2 first we prevent the move Bishop a
six now in place B should be seven okay
so I played King F and put the Queen
only two but again he just wants to go
to Casey a true keffe d eight and how do
i attack here what do you think
yes
No okay
so what do you think you need to spend
some time and come up with a plan I
would like a plan here I don't want just
the one wolf a plum a good plant here
because I spent some time and I think
this is the right plan in this position
plump we could but you know Bianca to
the King here it's a little bit also I
know I mean you could do that but then
he puts his rooks on see it in d8 and I
don't think you know it's going to be
much advantage so you need to if you
want you need something sharper a little
bit okay because it's a lot of moves you
know can get one g3 Kingi - it takes
time
any other ideas sort of plumb for white
here yes fine if you're gonna live in
Travers Queen it's fairly tight over
there I'm not sure that you could but I
think if we start if we try to trap the
Queen then I think see ya see like I
mean this is this is not very good for
us
rooks are not playing the king is there
so it's a we can't just now start
focusing on trapping the Queen because
we're probably not going to be able to
trap him we can try to maybe move him
away but I don't know if we're really
going to gain much out of it well the
thing is I close the center I have to be
very careful pushing any of my pawns
here because you push ePHI view create
light square weaknesses I don't think he
wants to play five right now that's not
very good so yeah well again whatever
you do you have to do kind of quickly
because we don't have too much time he
is going to put the rooks together then
it's going to be applying more pressure
and there might be some danger of you
know later on the game maybe Roxy - so I
mean I don't have so much time here I
have to yeah I think without this move
it's very hard to fight for a time to
cheer for why this move is really
necessary here
so if you look at the position of the
black king he doesn't have damn many
pieces around it so he has his bishop on
his seven but he doesn't have that many
pieces so if I can try to bring one more
piece into that track and try to open up
my bishops with a potential jump of the
night and queen then I can have lots of
pieces I could have possibly five pieces
attacking here so any only has one
defender
yeah any other ideas even if you're not
so sure it's okay we can discuss you
know defy what the thing is
without your rooks in a game you play d5
you will open up the position and d5 I
think you could just take take take
correct
very good h4 not only this is kind of
not I'm trying to just threaten anything
my main idea here is to go rook h3 rook
g3 that's the main idea to get the rook
into the game the rook is going to be
very active on g3 here and this is a
kind of a typical idea when you lose
your turn to castle and this is one of
the ideas that you can use to push the
pawn get the rook up to the side okay
but which mu can he play to create
counter play for example if you try a5
this could be lucid this is losses to
taketake who can find a move winning
move here quickly huh
d5 first here the bishop is protected so
first we push the pawn to attack him and
if he takes Bishop c4 okay so he can
play a five right away so he played rook
a c8 so normal move developing the rook
I follow it up with my idea rock h3 and
on ib8 strange-looking move but concrete
idea he wants to go Bishop a6 and
exchange the light square bishop if it
would have played through calf d8 I
would've just gone rook g3 and then I
have a very strong threat of d5 so this
look at this looks I think very
dangerous for black so he plays Knight
b8 now he wants to go Bishop h6 exchange
the bishops perhaps also again play
Queen a6 if we if he exchanges the
Queen's then I don't have much so again
bishop a 6 and then exchange Queens then
he can go Roxy - maybe so now again you
have to find a best move here
see time is everything in this position
so
of course you can play the rook g3 move
but you have something better
now he 5c in these positions our group
is ready to go rogue jittery right but
if you go rogue jitter you don't have a
thread what you need to do is you need
to make a move so when you go rogue g3
you have a very strong threat we can't
just attack it with the rook on g3 the
main idea is to have d5 right so we want
to make sure we open up the bishops
first so I go here
d5 what's in some point he needs to
watch out the capture also he took and
now
Rock G tray now that I think on g7 and
now I played f6
now there are two options here one is to
play g6 but and wants to play f6 g6
looks very unnatural because it weakens
the position and there are some nice
alliance in this situation you play
edie it goes here attacking the rook you
go Knight g5 it takes and who can find a
winning move now all right Queen h5
threatening checkmate on h7 he has to
take so as you can see we sacrifice the
rook on g3 and the Queen on h5 but we
have a checkmate so I think I see this
during the game but I'm sure there might
be some other options tube but g6 looks
really weakening so it's it's natural
movies f6 for a human to play f6 now
again see these positions the reason I
want I want to show you this game
because positions like this are kind of
hard to play also for the player who is
attacking because here for example I
have many different moves to choose from
b5 d h5 h6 there's so many different
things you can try to do here but you
have to really find the most precise
move here I was considering all this
moves here but then when I found the
move that I played I realized now my
attack is getting stronger because I'm
trying to make sure all my pieces are
involved into attack okay
yeah 94 94 now bishops are in the game
Lucas in a game but we have the Queen
and the night they're not really
participating yet so once we bring these
pieces into the game too
then it's going to be very difficult for
them so I go night to d4 now threatening
to play Knight f5 putting pressure on
the bishop once on h6 on g7 so he takes
so he just keeps on taking the pass he
took on define Knight takes only for now
now we can't capture a fish mister you
could take bishop takes but again a
strong move needs to be played first
okay strong move needs to be played
first huh absolutely bring another piece
into the game with temple now
threatening Queen g7 mate so he plays
rook f7
the rookies on seed he can take it so I
can't dad so okay for a moment okay I'm
down two pounds and looks like I don't
even have a threat yet
seems like Bach is holding 95 I could
play but I'm not sure if maybe he could
take the bishop it's it's messy 97 maybe
yeah
it's possible but I think the move in
the game it's it's it's a little better
yeah excellent excellent Bishop takes e4
now he cannot take the bishop because of
Queen c8 and now if he goes Queen a6
check I can just simply come back Bishop
d3 this was a very important move first
I didn't see this bishop did remove so I
was bit worried because I thought maybe
I don't have so much but then I realized
she checks me I can go back we should be
three in a crucial temple and then I go
Knight f5 then it's very strong so now I
took the pawn and now really all my
pieces are ready for the attack so now I
have a threat Bishop takes b7 and it's
not so easy for him to defend against
that threat and again he cannot take the
bishop because the seat is hanging so
here he spent a lot of time but
is already really bad for him so he
decided to play h5 try to deflect my
Queen from g4 but okay let's move now
weakens the position so what do you do
now after h5 yes Queen a6 oh yeah I
think they might move wrong actually I
played here anyway so I played Queen e6
but they have for some reason they put
Queen f5 in the database so I paid queen
ecigs and he is forced to take certain
so now he has to take on e4 because I
have this Bishop g6 threat and so many
threads now he can do anything so he
took a queen g6 he will take which is
six it takes it takes that's why
so he took because he couldn't see
anything else so he took I took on c8
now b8 is also hanging he cannot play
rook f8 because I go Queen e6 check back
this just loses because then I take the
bishop
I'm just upper rock so he realize he is
losing kill so I said okay I will just
go for this line maybe some time
pressure some create some tread so I
took now I'm an apple rook all I need to
do is just consolidate my position okay
so multi place Queen d2 it's still some
tricks so you have to play accurately
and here is very important moment in a
game because you know if I play Bishop
c3 as this Bishop d3 check again
probably I have some other ways to win
also here but what's the most precise
move here took me some time to find this
move but once I found this move I
realized I'm just winning and really no
counter play so I would like you to
spend some time because it's not a easy
move to find you have to really
calculate some lines because he wants to
take on b2 and then take on d4 a1 is
hanging sir
white to play he's threatening to take
my bishop
so you have to see his threat yeah you
must take a bishop
Bishop's III is a good mole also but he
has the check so I probably going to win
an exchange in that line
rookie one
yeah I think that's that's also winning
gear rock t1 is also rookie one is also
winning I think he has to play Bishop d3
then then I will get a position with the
extra pcs should be winning Luke takes
e4
um
okay maybe maybe something like that you
can do a queen a one check okay I could
I could probably even just go back
rookie one queen takes d4 Queen takes I
cannot go Queen takes a seven because of
Bishop c5 checking it to shaking yeah
yeah so maybe they maybe he yeah rook e1
Queen B - takes Queen a one check and
kinky - still Queen B - I think yeah
maybe something like this here so it's
not so clear probably still winning for
white somewhere there but the move in
the game is pretty strong now
yes yeah it's possible yeah I mean I'm
up a rook so there are many ways to try
to win but I like you to find a move in
the game because I think it's the
strongest and really doesn't it really
ends the game I think game just a game
ended like in just a few more moves here
but you really have to calculate what's
going to happen if you make this move
yeah you were there so in this kind of
positions when opponent makes the move
attacking your pieces what you need to
do is you you know of course natural
instinct is to start thinking about
defense right away but I want you to
look at the move that you can make and
you attack his piece ok so what can you
do to actually forget that he's
attacking your Bishop you make a move to
attack one of his PC run with pieces huh
Queen e8 now now we attack the rook you
cannot go back because we can take only
7 very strong move he played Bishop d5
so but now if it takes this is the one
you needed to calculate it's not very
long it's just couple of moves take now
threating mate so it's funny in this
position it looks like you know King is
exposed to bishops Queen it should be
something very bad enough for whitey but
actually he doesn't have anything here
because the knight on d4 is doing a
really good job actually guarding very
important squares and he doesn't have
time to take because of the mate so he
can give one more check and I simply
come up and now the bishop is hanging
and again I'm putting checkmate on g7 so
he cannot do anything
check takes and
is losing so after I found the Queen yet
I realized if he takes I just take one
of seven Queen a one I just simply walk
my king to e3 so he has no choice you
played Bishop d5 and now can you find
the winning idea
again there must be a few ways to win
here at least it was a nice it's a nice
finish
-
got it have their completely calculated
with it everything works well okay
excellent
rook takes his seven yeah he has to take
back with the King because if he takes
with the rook then we just take on a try
with the check he goes back then we also
take the bishop with a check and then
just probably Queen b3 and look T 1 so
it's winning so he has to take no choice
now I was up a rook so I gave the rook
back
follow it up my Knight f5 check now if
he goes to g6 then you just take 107
with the check so anyway so he has to go
here and now
now you don't need to do anything really
complicated here so you just take the
bishop and you're threatening checkmate
in two so if it takes only seven I just
go Queenie seven check so I really
cannot do anything so now his last
chance he played Queen Bishop takes g2
check last attempt here but again you
still have to be accurate and I made the
move instantly because I calculated this
Bishop g2 move so what do you do king
jumong you don't want to take this beef
you take it's going to you might be able
to actually make a draw so it's whoop g7
check and some some tracks so you play
king g1 and he immediately resigned
because now I have Queen f7 thread Queen
Gaz
26 so you cannot do anything okay so it
was he played like a rarer line in the
opening but he didn't play the bishop
before move which allow me to play three
okay now let's do a couple of endgame
positions okay
let's take a look at this opposite
colors endgame what what do you know
about the opposite color bishops very
draw ish that's one very Jewish
sometimes to even two extra pounds now
guarantee you the win
like for example same color bishops two
extra points it's almost always a win
but there are many many positions
without the color it's it's a draw like
for example this position do you think
white can win this or with the proper
play black and make a draw here
aha draw aha any of your annuities any
of you you know how to hold this
position what you need to do to make a
draw no okay that's good this is a you
can get this position this you know in
your games you can reach this position
it's important to know how to defend
this position this is a draw okay but
you have to know what to do to make a
draw okay if you if you just sit and
wait in this position you will lose like
for example strategy like this you just
if you don't do anything eventually
you're going to lose he's going to
advance and move the King back push the
pawn to e5 King goes back and then it's
probably losing okay so what you need to
do in this position is he's going to try
to advance these pawns he's going to try
to play g5 f-4e for adventure so you
need to put this pawn on g5 here first
so let's say king after you put the pawn
on d5 very important to put the pawn on
g5 here now in order to win White is
going to try to create two connected
passed pawns right now here's one pass
pawn and you can create the two
connected passed pawns okay so he's
going to have to play --kinky --kinky
for for example now you just you don't
want to allow him to come here so you go
King f6 and now you place f4
you take
now he can take more natural take with a
jeep on towards the center but we'll
take a look at both ways he takes it
doesn't really matter because if you
know how to hold this position then it
doesn't matter for you which way he
takes let's take a look at things with a
jeep on now in this position you already
have to do much you just have to make
sure you keep the bishop on this pawn
okay for now you keep the pressure on
this pawn so you just see the squares
you just go here for now so he can't
really move the King go forward so he
has to stay with a pawn right I just the
same thing now he goes here now he is
that he has a threat he wants to play
this move so for example if you play
this move here now you could lose okay
so now in this position you need to
control the e5 square because you
already have the king controlling it so
if you control with the bishop remember
if you can sacrifice your Bishop for two
parts it's going to be a draw so that's
a lot of this endgame to draw at the end
because you know if it's one pound
versus three you exchange one and then
you sacrifice the bishop because in NDM
it is possible to sacrifice the bishop
for two pounds so now if you play the f5
you just put the [ __ ] twenty-five he
can never win and he can come here and
again you just keep the pressure on the
f4 pawn first you put the pressure on
the e3 pawn and now you put the pressure
on f4 pawn he can't do anything so
eventually in some point he's going to
have to push because he can go away
because takes and now he pushes take
take and you make a draw okay this
strategy works so like right now it
depends on the fourth rank it will also
work if his pants are on the fifth rank
okay but let's see if our response reach
the sixth rank for white third rank for
black then you cannot hold with this
strategy so I'll show you why
so let's say we go here
well let's take a look at the other way
if it captures it will be also useful to
see if let's say it takes this way now
we can't really stop and pushing the
Jeep and so we put the pressure on f4 so
he pushes we go here now very important
in this position now you pressure on a4
and if you place f5 which will we have
to play here in order to make a draw
bishop d8 yes bishop d8 now you putting
pressure on g5 now you threaten to take
and of course g6 you just block it
Bishop f6 and if it goes have six what
do you do sacrifice you make a draw so
so this is the last position pawns are
on the fifth rank that you can still
make a draw now let's take a look if we
for example in this position let's play
let's go back to the main line so let's
say we
actually okay
so let's say we reach this position now
looks like it's same kind of position
you have the same concept but here
you're not going to be able to make a
draw here not because his king can come
in or anything it's just because your
bishop doesn't have many scores to go to
so you don't have another square here to
go to keep the pressure and also control
the e7 yeah well if there was a square
yeah if there was a see nine square yes
you're right that wouldn't mean in draw
but unfortunately after Bishop e5 so
let's see we make it white to move this
position he he plays Bishop e5
and now black is in sucks monk if he
moves the bishop away you play e7 e8 to
win the game so he has to move the King
away so he cannot really keep the
control if you can keep the control of
the seven square it's going to be a draw
but he can't so again remember if the
pass on the sixth to correctly passed
pawn you're going to lose on a fifth on
the 4/3 it's all draw ok if you're
trying to defend because now is going to
go here and then it's going to push ok
so it's not very difficult but you have
to remember the way that you defend ok
now let me change the position a little
bit a little bit different pawn
structure but ID is pretty much the same
so you're playing with the black pieces
here so you know in order to win you
just have to advance your puns ok that's
what you have to try to do now you
playing with black which rules we have
to play here because if you don't play
this move you could lose this game
you're cut loose but this move will make
it easier for you to make a draw which
move is necessary huh Bishop is already
on f5 defy yeah exactly you need to
exchange the spawn because when he has
less pants the idea of drawing by
sacrificing the bishop or two pants is
going to work so first we play this move
he plays before continue let's see if
you can hold this position now continue
absolute liquidate he takes you have to
look at the notation F what's the
correct move here which part we need to
put a pressure on now
absolutely check
you could cook but better you don't need
to go to c5 if you go to c5 there you
know he can check and start pushing the
pawn with the check you don't you could
lose anyway you're not going to be able
to black get the spawns with a king our
idea is to get to the right position
where we can sacrifice right so we go to
the light square okay now he goes here
now let's see what do you do here so
what's the correct move here
you could play Bishop d7 but remember
you have to put the pressure on the C
pawn here right you want to force him to
push Bishop d7 you could shuffle move
the King may be trying to do something
and still a draw but Bishop f7 very
important because that because if you
play Bishop g8 it's a problem he pushes
because we no longer have the Bishop to
e8 move and in these positions it's not
you're not going to be able to defend
from the side or from this angle because
now he can try to improve his King this
way okay so this is not a good way to
defend so you probably lose here so
that's why you have to make sure you go
fish appear keep the pressure on okay
and don't go to the last rank anyway
it's not a good at because you have less
squares to go to when you put the bishop
on the last rank and this kind of
positions always put the bishop on a
square that has more squares to go to
and now he has to push and now again if
you allow this move you lose unless you
can take that pawn so now you defend
from which square fish not from here
again we should be 8
and now it goes here only move that will
make a draw is see if you didn't have
this move you would lose because now he
is controlling this square you have to
go away then he puts c6 he wins so you
really have this square so that's fine
you can make a drawn the fifth-ranked
that's the that's the last one okay
after that you're not going to be able
to do it yes 40 pushes to see on the c5
that you just again you just keep the
pressure on the pond yeah just don't put
your Bishop on the last rank that's all
remember that don't put the bishop on
last name you just go back and forth
each 6s 7 e 6 f7 eventually he can't
just activate the King he'll drop upon
so he has to go here then you go here as
soon as he pushes then you go fish b8
okay you have to defend but also attack
the pawn you can't just depend upon you
have to make sure your Bishop is also
attacking the pawn it's an active
defense because you want to threaten
something b6 again you put the bishop on
c6 can't do anything so he's going to
try to do something you just go here he
goes here you go here and c6 takes
thanks very important to note this
endgame because it's you can get this
position and if you don't know that for
example on the fifth track it's still a
draw on a six it's loss then you will
know the way to defend so I hope you
understand now how to defend the
positions like this when you're down two
pounds remember you exchanged one pawn
first and then you defend a pot against
the past but you have to make sure the
bishop is active attacking the pawns
okay so again connected passed pawns are
very important okay but without it it's
just like for example position like this
it's going to be more winning chances if
the polity is on E
Lauren F fell further aways from the
other planets more winning chances okay
and for example in this position if
let's say he has two pounds
so here's let's say okay how can you
make a draw here what would be the
easiest way for you to make a drawing
what do you need to do here I probably
take it yeah yeah but do you know what
you need to do here to make a draw the
plan yeah
aha but it's very important which one
yeah pawn on a side began why okay you
can guess push it back on the edge file
you get a check with the black bishop
well it's actually it's if yeah well in
the second place your Bishop for one of
the farms which one yeah a part of the
h1 is only one correct yes why is that
yeah you have to know that for example
if you reach a position with your King
on a8 here let's say we go here let's
say we yeah Bishop let's say he goes
here we go here and okay it's pushing we
go here you put the King here you can
sacrifice your Bishop for this pawn when
he plays h7 then he has a passed pawn
but he has what is called the wrong
color Bishop with a dark square Bishop
and apart on a file he cannot win this
position but your King has to be on be
several on a8 in this position if it's
not there then he might be able to win
so remember that so this kind of you
know same thing if the pawn was on G or
F file that's why it's much easier to
draw when the pawns are on a a or H file
here okay you just have to remember you
have to know that this position is a
wrong color bishop you put the King
there's let's say he goes here I don't
know if everyone is familiar but this
position white cannot win because he
cannot move the King from the white
corner here so it's going to be a sucks
funk I mean he's going to still mate
still make yeah so let's take a look
again
now going to be a stalemate so it goes
here so he's going to get closer but see
this is still mate already so he can't
really do much so you can move check and
you go to the corner and he cannot win
haha yeah I heard about that yeah yeah
yeah okay good so sum up of the color
queens can with the client game against
guru [ __ ] and also some opposite color
bishop which is very important to know